Traductor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
La mayoría de libros te dirán que el
Imperio romano cayó en el siglo V d.C.
Pero esto hubiera sido una gran sorpresa
para millones de personas
que vivieron en el Imperio romano
durante la Edad Media.
Este Imperio romano medieval,
al cual nos referimos hasta hoy
como el Imperio bizantino,
comenzó en el 330 d.C.
Es cuando Constantino,
el primer emperador cristiano,
mudó la capital del Imperio romano
a una nueva ciudad llamada Constantinopla,
fundada en la antigua
ciudad griega Bizancio.
Cuando los visigodos saquearon
Roma en el 410 d.C.
y las provincias occidentales del Imperio
fueron conquistadas por bárbaros,
la capital del Este de Constantino
permaneció como asiento de emperadores.
Allí, generaciones de emperadores
gobernaron por los próximos 11 siglos.
Compartiendo continuidad
con el clásico Imperio romano
dieron al Imperio bizantino ventajas
tecnológicas y artísticas sobre sus vecinos,
a quienes los bizantinos
consideraban bárbaros.
En el siglo IX, visitantes
de más allá de la frontera
estaban asombrados con
los elegantes arcos y cúpulas
del palacio imperial en Constantinopla.
Un par de leones dorados
flanqueaban el trono imperial.
Un órgano escondido hacía a los leones
rugir mientras invitados caían de rodillas
Pájaros dorados cantaban
en un árbol de oro cercano.
Ingenieros romanos medievales
incluso usaban motores hidráulicos
para elevar el trono imperial en el aire.
Otros aspectos heredados
de la antigua cultura romana
se podían ver en la ropa del emperador,
desde su vestimenta tradicional
hasta las togas,
y en los tribunales,
donde seguían usando la Ley Romana.
La clase trabajadora bizantina
tenía vidas similares
a sus contrapartes de la Antigua Roma;
muchos practicaron o tuvieron
oficios comerciales
como cerámica,
peletería,
pesca,
tejidos,
y manufactura de seda.
Pero, por supuesto, el Imperio bizantino
no solo descansó sobre
los laureles de la Antigua Roma.
Los artistas innovaron, creando vastos
mosaicos y tallas de mármol ornamentadas.
Sus arquitectos construyeron
numerosas iglesias,
una de las cuales, Hagia Sofía,
tenía una cúpula tan alta que decían
que colgaba de una cadena del cielo.
El Imperio fue cuna de grandes
intelectuales como Anna Kommene.
Como princesa imperial en el siglo XII,
Anna dedicó su vida a
la filosofía y la historia.
Su relato del reinado de su padre
es la principal fuente histórica
de la historia política bizantina
en los tiempos de la Primera Cruzada.
Otro erudito, Leo el Matemático,
inventó un sistema de balizas
a lo ancho del Imperio,
que ahora es Grecia y Turquía.
Extendiéndose más de 700 kilómetros,
este sistema permitía avisar al emperador
de invasores en la frontera del Imperio
en una hora desde su avistamiento
desde la frontera.
Pero sus avances no pudieron
proteger al Imperio eternamente.
En 1203, un ejército de cruzados
franceses y venecianos
hicieron un trato con un hombre
llamado Alexios Angelos.
Alexios era el hijo
de un emperador depuesto,
y prometió a los cruzados vastas riquezas
y apoyo para volver a tomar
el trono de su tío.
Alexios tuvo éxito,
pero después de un año,
la población se rebeló y Alexios
fue depuesto y asesinado.
Así que el ejército sin pagar
volvió su agresión contra Constantinopla.
Encendieron enormes fuegos,
que destruyeron incontables trabajos
de la literatura y arte antiguo medieval,
dejando cerca de un tercio
de la población sin hogar.
La ciudad fue recuperada tras 50 años
por el emperador Miguel Paleólogo.
pero su restaurado Imperio
nunca recuperó todo el territorio
que los Cruzados habían conquistado.
En 1453, el emperador otomano Mehmed
el Conquistador, capturó Constantinopla,
dando un fin conclusivo al Imperio romano.
A pesar de la conquista otomana,
muchos hablantes de griego
del Mediterráneo oriental
continúan llamándose a sí mismos
romanos hasta principios del siglo XXI.
De hecho, no fue hasta el Renacimiento
que el término "Imperio bizantino"
fue usado por primera vez.
Para los europeos occidentales,
el Renacimiento era reconectar
con la sabiduría de la Antigüedad.
Y como la existencia de
un Imperio romano medieval
sugiere que los europeos nunca
perdieron contacto con la Antigüedad,
los europeos occidentales querían
trazar una línea clara entre épocas.
Para distinguir mejor el clásico
Imperio romano pagano de habla latina
del Imperio romano medieval,
cristiano, de habla griega,
los académicos denominaron a este último
como "bizantino".
Y así, 100 años después de haber
caído, nació el Imperio bizantino.